is going
through it he got fired from his job and
kicked out of the house
all because of his relationship with
what makes this situation even worse is
that
he hasn't even spoken to brittany in a
while
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
sacrifices seem to backfire on the
latest episode of the other way
ariella made a choice to go through with
giving birth in ethiopia
so benyam could be there and her
experience was
terrifying
no no no no
no no okay
okay okay i asked her
was it all worth it we'll get to her
response in just a few but first
let's start with yazan whose
life seems to be falling apart while
britney's
back in the u.s
[Music]
met up with his long time friend
muhammad who has
never really been fond of his
relationship with
brittany
[Music]
foreign
look i imagine that those pictures would
be a lot
for any parent you have to take in yazam
went on to say that his dad
thinks britney is playing games and
lying to him
which we all know is not completely
false
foreign
is where i started to feel really bad
for yazan
because while he's essentially choosing
brittany
over his family she's in chicago with
her mom and her sister thinking of more
ways to stall yazan
after finding out that she's not getting
a divorce
anytime soon yeah i went to court
yesterday
and i didn't get a damn thing
i go up there and i find out the clerk's
office
did not put the paperwork in the system
for the judge that
i that i gave to them i really don't
understand how i got a court date
you would think that if my paperwork
wasn't in the system
they wouldn't have summoned me in the
first place which is
super frustrating that i came all the
way from jordan
for this so now brittany has to refile
and wait once again for everything to be
approved by the judge
which means she's staying in the u.s a
bit longer
yazan revealed that since he's been
kicked out
he's been hopping from place to place he
even stayed on the street
for a few days i know at the core of
things
she doesn't mean any harm by lying about
her divorce
she thinks she's protecting something
but she's not at this point it's just so
unfair
that yazan is suffering such major
consequences
because she just won't be honest
she put it on him she had to
yazan is whipped his friend knows it
his family knows it and he knows it
is
his own judgment right now and he has
mentally struggling
he's starting to feel as if everything
his parents said about brittany
was true and he wasn't smart enough
to realize it himself
although brittany is definitely wrong i
think she does care about yazan
she just underestimated what she was
truly getting herself into
he's more like trying to just please his
family and his parents he can't even
think about what he wants for himself
because they are so damn overbearing
her sister's face sums up this entire
situation and think about this britney's
family
they only know what's going on on the
surface
she admitted that she's holding back
from telling her mom and sister
everything that happened in jordan
because she doesn't want them to get
upset
but even with the amount of information
they have
they're more than concerned britney is
light years away from
what a muslim woman would be she's
just not ready for that are you gonna
convert i mean i don't know
i want for her to be happy but i'm
really concerned you know
about my sister she's grown but she's
still my little sister
i don't know i don't know i'm sorry that
was such
a real moment unfortunately based off of
the teaser for the rest of the season
things seem as if they're only gonna get
worse between these two
all right well let's get into ariella
who told me that her storyline
is about to get even more intense
as well during this episode ariella
and binium's anxiety was through the
roof
as doctors were trying to prepare her
for the c-section
ariella had me scared for her after the
meds
finally kicked in the surgery was
underway
but there were still some frightening
moments
respiration rate is not good
the baby can't cry
you can breathe now ariela and binium
welcomed
a healthy baby boy whom they named
avielle
into the world and of course binium
was elated
[Music]
oh how sweet well once ariella woke up
and they got her into a room we were
able to see her
get into mommy mode which was just
so cute i love you baby you're so soft
the last thing i remember is telling the
doctors just to give me a minute so i
could calm down and then i woke up to
see my beautiful little baby boy sucking
on my boob
he's so cute and you're a lot smaller
than
i thought maybe you would be i knew i
wanted to be a mom but i didn't know if
i was ready
and then i didn't have a choice i was
gonna be a mom
why are you so sweet it's amazing it's
shocking it's
so i have no words to describe this
feeling oh
that gives me all the feels i have baby
fever y'all
i love to hear that you know who else i
love to hear from
ariela's mom hi mom
hi er congratulations thanks
how do you feel tired and in pain
are you in a lot of pain are they giving
you something for pain
i i they gave me something i don't know
what it is but uh it comes and it goes
you know
you'll get over that fast how's the baby
good he's just a
suckling right now everything else is
fine
everything's fine he looks good looks
like i didn't make too many mistakes
is he cute he's cute he has a lot of
hair
oh my god i need a picture of what he
looks like
i wasn't saying for you the little man
is her
twin he's such a cutie
i'm so relieved and glad that everything
worked out for her
and the baby after that dramatic
delivery experience
i spoke to ariela last week and i had to
ask her
girl was delivering in ethiopia
just so you could have bennion by your
side worth it
here's what she had to say the one thing
i kept saying and people kept asking me
like aren't you afraid to have a baby in
ethiopia and my answer was always like
i'm afraid to have a baby
like in the u.s in ethiopia and you i'm
afraid like
i've never had a baby before you know
this is a scary thing as it is but then
you know i obviously would have gotten
great medical care if i
had you know been with my parents and
everything but yeah i think it was worth
it because
after you know the baby is born like
having that moment where we're together
and you know it was like everything any
problem that we ever had before like it
didn't matter because we experienced
this moment together
ariella is a trooper
and binium he is lucky to have her by
his side
all right well next week on the other
way brittany
is on finally talk
i am losing a lot you don't lose
anything
with me don't want to have this
conversation you always say i'm not
losing out on anything i change
everything in my life because i love you
you must change yourself plus
ariella stops the doctors from
circumcising
i don't want him to do this right now
[Music]
i'm not sure if i'm supposed to be
laughing at that or
not i just know benyam is like oh my
goodness
oh my goodness all right 90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with et because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time